i'm not new to this dating game thing
obviously i've got the salt pepper in
the beard i've been
i've been out there um
online dating profiles
and some of you guys today are funny you
know i laugh when i hear you're all oh
you know women today and this and that
it's a rig game and blah blah blah and
you know dating apps suck and all it's
it's been that way for a while i think
it was around 2000
for
2003 for in and around there that they
started to get some traction
um
i was involved in a startup in the early
2000s
dealing with this one called lemontonic
which was i think
one of the founders came from the lava
life world so
so these were the two main ones
and everything that i'm about to go
through here with you
is going to
absolutely um
like clarify anything that you need to
know and create a little bit of laughs
for you along the way when it comes to
deciphering the code in the matrix if
you will uh paul perry says i was the
ultimate beta you and shooter tomassi
basically saved my life been through so
much crap but i feel like i'm on the
right track it took me 40 years spinning
the crap out of plates right now attaboy
all right
let me open up my list because i posted
this here on the community tab
of the youtube channel this is a
different community tab from this one by
the way this one's mine the one i'm
about to show you is the public one
all right
all right so i'm just going to rip
through these
wild what do you think that means
generally that means drinking drug
problem addictive personality
uh difficult to control right
um you know you're gonna have to reel
that one in if you know what i'm saying
means 50. it's definitely it definitely
doesn't mean 39. 29 doesn't mean 29 and
39 doesn't mean 39. whenever you see
that age on a dating app it's it's
definitely into the next uh
decade that they were born for sure um
there's always this like rounding down
issues matt like women tend to lie about
their age and their looks like they'll
use older photography
um or they'll say that the 39 if they're
like you know 45 or 50 or something like
that to try to capture you know the
younger crowd or to hold out uh that
they're younger than what they actually
are i mean women inherently know that
their true values and their youth and
their beauty and their reproductive
rights i mean it's been that way for
millions of years evolutionary
psychology has confirmed this that's why
you see this on you know the dating
sites uh that way why it's rounded down
sort of uh sort of thing
um oh you want me to share the screen
off sure hold on a second but
you don't trust me to read it out you
don't like my beautiful voice you just
want to read instead
i don't even know if you're going to be
able to see this on the screen here let
me make it a little bit bigger
so this one's my personal list and then
i'm going to go through the comments and
i'm going to go through the feedback
from some of the other guys
uh don't waste my time
alpha widowed several times guaranteed
um
any time you see don't waste my time
you're going to be dealing with a
demanding
pushy
you might see don't waste my time in
conjunction with something else in a bio
like boss girl
you know stuff like that they're gonna
be difficult to deal with basically the
translation is they've made some bad
choices in life they don't want to take
ownership for it
and or they've been alpha widowed
several times but they've got a notch
count you know up there which is why
they're like trying to push
for the good guys which ultimately
they're
you know it's funny because they push
for the good guys on the dating app
especially past the epiphany phase past
30 but they don't really want to be with
the good guys they still want to be with
the chads you know they still want to be
with the you know the guys with the
broad shoulders narrow waist the muscle
chisel jaw the deep voice you know the
guys you guys know right some of you are
those guys you know some of you have
been those guys
about average so whenever you see like
average you know as far as a descriptive
term used for body type up i remember um
you know it was like i don't know what
were the options thin
average
i think they had athletic
uh thick
um and they've got like something like
big and boned or whatever i don't know
the bb whatever it is you know the one
i'm talking about
you know homie don't mess with anything
above average uh but whenever you see
something like above average as a
descriptive term it it generally means
like 30 to 60 pounds overweight
um love to travel that means looking for
a dude to take me on trips
i'm not even kidding
like most of the time when you see these
like girls on
uh social media sites like instagram and
stuff like that and they've got
something like i love to travel or
they've got a lot of travel photography
and they're young you know they're
clearly not
self-made or anything like that
somebody's paying for it somebody's
paying for it guaranteed right and and
it's generally not her
again you know remember men are success
objects and women are beauty sex objects
so
those things go in conjunction with one
another you know guy has resources she's
got beauty let's go travel it's
basically the way that it pans out in
those scenarios
independent
what does that mean
you will decide nothing
and it and it sometimes means not
entirely independent independent you
know can sometimes mean uh i rely on my
ex-husband for child support and alimony
or i rely on my ex-husband the
government for child support alimony and
child tax credits you know sort of thing
um but um yeah like anybody that's
independent doesn't need to declare that
they're independent they just are at the
end of the day i've never i've never uh
uploaded a dating bio and published it
and said independent on it that's just
foolish i mean no woman looks for
independent you know in a guy's quality
but they somehow think that it's
something that we um you know look
towards are you young are you hot are
you thin do you know do you have
culinary skills you know these are the
sorts like are you not going to nag me
sort of thing like these are the things
that we're interested in right
independent equals you will decide
nothing no hookups definitely hooks up
if you're a chad that's basically what
that one means um
no hookups is usually closely correlated
with don't waste my time
and uh you know she's been you know
she's racked up a bit of a number bit of
a body count uh and saying that she's
not into the hookups but she will
definitely absolutely positively hook up
if you're a chad
all of you guys out there in the
comments say what's up right now confirm
you know or deny you tell me
another one of my favorites is get me
off this app
all that means is i've been with a lot
of dudes here and i'm running out of new
inventory to deal with so get me the
hell out of here because i got nothing
else
uh jiren's in the chat he says no
hookups equals she's game to go and
usually come right over hey listen it's
happened to all of us at least once
uh it's happened at least once if you
got some game
um get me off this app and with a lot of
guys next one
my son aiden is my world
translation you will be an atm and pay
for him that's basically where we're
getting at with this
stay well away i mean i've got it in
my 20 red flag chapter in the book it's
red flag number 12 single moms
you guys should not be dealing with
single moms on any kind of long-term
basis short-term dating fine you know if
you absolutely have to
um but
it's
listen just
read the book the unplugged alpha it's
on amazon grab it
you'll understand why it's it's just
worth your time in that one but my son
aiden is my world usually equals you'll
be an atm and pay for him that's
essentially what she's looking for
that's what the translation is it also
you know essentially means that you will
decide nothing your opinion means
nothing and you will have to bend the
knee to a child that isn't even yours
most of the time right kid wants to have
a little spazz and brat out guess whose
side she's going to be on her son aiden
right
beautiful eyes equals fat
i've seen this one a few times and um
it's usually cropped out photographs
zoomed in right around heavily made up
like heavy makeup eyes
or you know maybe she's got great eyes
like a like a deep blue uh
or like a nice colored green eye sort of
thing
um
hey listen just make sure you get a head
to toe picture before you make any uh
you know calls on the whole beautiful
eye thing if you know what i'm saying
foodie
equals doesn't cook and demands fancy
restaurants you pay for
i think i uh i think i shared one of
these um
here on my
twitter let me see if i can find it
it was a it was a funny meme i got sent
to me you guys dm me these things all
the freaking time i gotta find it
because it exemplifies the whole foodie
thing
uh
there it is
um boom at the stream i don't know if
you guys can see this but it says it's a
it's a dating profile this is courtney
age 29. of course it's always 29 right
translation what does that mean boys 30
35.
if you can't handle me at my worst you
don't deserve me at my best her worst
who the f is jenna dude says my sister
place is burning down you know she's
going nuts over the phone her best i
tried to make spaghetti but burnt it so
now you get to take me out
uh
foodie doesn't cook and demands fancy
restaurants you pay for athletic
equals flat chested
unless she's had some augmentation work
generally but yeah
it just happens
ready to settle down
oh let me put it back on the screen for
you guys
let's go a little bit bigger hopefully
you can see it this way you're gonna
have to watch it on a console if i do
this way
ready to settle down
means that she's been with every alpha
she's been on the carousel and wants a
beta male provider now
she wants some guy that's just good
enough
i mean she might already have kids in
tow and she doesn't want anymore she
just wants a guy that's just good enough
to pay for everything
or she's got baby rabies and she's
looking for a just good enough guy with
reasonable genes to reproduce with and
have him pay for everything and 50
percent of the time she's going to leave
him seven to ten years down the road so
that's a big translation for ready to
settle
but the older that she is
okay i'm gonna say this again
29 ready to settle is not the same thing
as 39 ready to settle i'm going to say
this 31 ready to settle is not the same
thing as 41 ready to settle
ready to settle 41 is a dangerous ready
to settle okay
i'm just saying understand that
boss girl equals disagreeable and
annoying you ever see those hashtag boss
girls
i'm a boss girl
she's a disagreement she's disagreeable
and she's annoying trust me alpha woman
that's one of my favorites by the way
there is no such thing as an alpha woman
okay
there's just women
there's some difficult women but you
can't i mean they think that they're
alphas i went out and got my law degree
so now i'm a lawyer i went out and got
my accounting degree so now i'm an
accountant i went out and i'm a c-suite
blah blah blah i'm an alpha woman
just understand that just means bossy af
adventurous
equals
i know my worth equals i think i'm a
queen and you should too
generally speaking
when somebody is worth something they
don't walk around saying i know my worth
now
a few years into a relationship and
somebody's being taken advantage of
and they need to put their foot down and
say look
lady i know my worth or maybe she says
it to him sort of thing that's a
different story but you do not go and
declare i know my worth in a dating bio
because that means that she's an
entitled brat generally speaking she
thinks that she's a queen and she
believes that you should believe so as
well
bubbly equals won't stop talking
hey where are the lies you know you guys
tell me in the comments it's you know
the chat is there you let me know
financially independent
equals getting alimony and child support
you